hey friend i've got a secret technique
for inventing brand new body tracers and
if you follow these steps i can just
about guarantee that you'll wind up with
a body tracer that no one has ever seen
before drexer from drexfactor poi
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today
we're going to dive into poi body
tracers and how you can create your own
unique ones before we dive in i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spinballs
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard
lane machinski and becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission based upon
the analytics for my channel i'm going
to hazard a guess that body tracers are
one of the most popular types of poi
tricks out there and it's easy to see
why they're slinky they're sexy and
they're actually super easy to invent
wait now what haven't all the flowerbase
poi tricks been discovered and done now
for more than a decade nope in fact with
the technique i give you in this video i
can more or less guarantee that you'll
be creating a body tracer for the first
time ever
but to understand how we're gonna have
to lay down a bit of groundwork way back
in the day poi spinner leo ikaza came up
with a way to systematize body tracers
by breaking them down into component
reels see technically speaking you can
think of most body tracers as really
just being simple reels around different
parts of the body with the hand moving
between these different positions this
system was extended by cryptic firecat
in later work but for the purposes of
this video we're going to simplify it
down to just six points those six points
are as follows i imagine there are
several zones around my body coinciding
with points of negative space between
different parts of my body counting them
off clockwise relative to the performer
we get that point number one is above
the left shoulder point number two is
below the left armpit point number three
is right next to the left hip
point number four is right next to the
right hip
point number five is below the right
armpit
and point number six is above the right
shoulder the actual order and location
of these points is kind of irrelevant
but arranging them this way makes it
easy for me to remember which point is
which
so now
what do we do with all of them first up
practice performing poi reels going back
and forth in each location to make sure
you're good and comfortable with all of
them each is about to become real
important okay now grab a six sided dice
or d6 for short and roll the thing six
times stick with me i swear this is
going somewhere after rolling the dice
write down each of the six numbers your
roles produced and memorize the order
that they go in remember the numbers
that we assigned to the zones around our
body well we're now going to perform a
real at the location that corresponds
with each number you wrote down in order
so in my case i rolled six
four
one
two
four
five
so i'm going to move back and forth
between reels above my right shoulder
next to my right hip
above my left shoulder
under my left armpit
next to my right hip and under my right
armpit
lather rinse repeat essentially what i
did was come up with a random series of
locations to perform these reels in
given that we're rolling a d6 for six
times it means that there are 46
656 possible combinations that you could
roll
with the odds of each body tracer being
produced at nearly one in forty seven
thousand
i'd say there's a really good chance the
body tracer you create is one that
nobody else ever has done of course we
do have some caveats here for one we're
only doing it with one hand we could use
both hands by spinning the poi split
time same direction through each
location and just keeping in mind the
order that each poi goes through that
point with another possibility would be
to roll the left and right hand
separately it'd be pretty easy to wind
up in a position where the two hands get
in each other's way though another
caveat of course would be that given
that the order of points for each of
these body tracers is random there isn't
likely to be a pattern that emerges from
it poi spinners are pretty fond of their
patterns overall and it's unlikely that
this technique will produce something
that will be immediately recognizable to
a poi spinner themselves or to their
audience but with all that said i think
it's a fun exercise for extending the
use of these component reels
and if you want to this system can be
extended cryptic firecat took a similar
tact but assigned many more zones around
the body including those with behind the
back or behind the head hand placement
you could extend this out to a total of
25 positions including around each elbow
and wrist knees and ankles as well as
behind the head or between the legs and
with the arms stretched behind the body
to opposite shoulder opposite armpit or
opposite hip this gets super tricky to
maneuver through but the overall
technique for creating body tracers with
this extended system is much the same as
the one that we've gone over already you
just need to pick random numbers between
1 and 25 this can really result in a lot
of wild and offbeat patterns but if you
like the possibilities the first
exercise opened up this can really take
them in a lot of exciting new directions
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and to help my channel grow also
if you use this technique to invent your
own body tracers then please post video
and tag me i'd love to see the rabbit
holes that this leads people down this
video would not be possible if not for
the wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos
tutorials and more i'm on a mission to
bring poi spinning and flow arts to the
wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies so help me
do it head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signup you can do that
at the link in the description or the
card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you what do
you think about this method for creating
body tracers cool and unique way of
simplifying something complex or am i
just way too fond of my dice from catan
you be the judge i will leave a link to
a playlist of other videos i've done in
this vein down in the description as
well as up on screen if you are watching
on youtube make sure to get outside to
flow and i will see you with a new video
on friday
peace